you
I'm delighted to welcome and to MSR
Redmond and as an assistant professor at
the Department of Psychology at Berkeley
and she heads the CCN lab computational
cognitive neuroscience did I get the
order right and she's done amazing work
and in speaking to her today morning I
realized that she offers a complimentary
perspective to what Manuel Blum spoke
about just a couple of weeks back on the
conscious Turing machines well here is a
cognitive scientist who will give us the
cognitive science viewpoint on working
memory and I I do remember reading one
of your papers a few years back on how
much of reinforcement learning and
humans is just working memory versus
actual reinforcement learning I'm very
eager to hear more about bringing our
ell computation neural coding together
looking for to the talk great thank you
very much thank you for the invitation
it's a it's very exciting for me to be
here I don't get that often a chance to
talk to her to people in AI and I think
we could all benefit more from from our
discussion often so so that's that's
really great so I prepared a talk that
has two parts and that is supposed to be
a one-hour but I was told to expect lots
of interruptions which I really welcome
it's always hard to make sure in advance
what people know and what don't so
please feel free to ask questions at any
time and I made it so that if we go
through a first part I'll be very happy
so so so that's good okay okay um so I'm
going in my lab I my life is called
computational cognitive neuroscience and
I really tried to take the three angles
to try and to understand how humans make
decisions and and learn and I focus on
reinforcement learning and I'm going to
very quickly define that because I think
it means different things to different
communities actually so that's the whole
a I community who means something AI and
more generally applied math and computer
science community humans
something with reinforcement learning as
the cognitive crowd who looks at
behavior and means something else
and as the neuroscience crowd who means
something else again and of course this
is all related but it's also different
in very important ways that I'm going to
try to talk about ok so I probably don't
need to explain this part to you guys
the computation the way I think of it at
least from my external point of view is
that it's really a class of learning
algorithm that have are trying to find
policies that maximize a fairly specific
kind of cost function minimize cost
function and you're going to be fairly
disappointed in the kind of
reinforcement learning algorithm I use
it's essentially the simplest you can
think of the one where you get when
estimate of the value get a reward
prediction error and update your body so
most of my reinforcement learning
algorithms are going to be limited to
that today sorry in the psychology
cognition cognitive science field we
think of reinforcement learning as a set
of behaviors and also a set of tasks
that we use to probe this behavior and
that's everything that we're essentially
we have to learn from feedback that's
either reinforcing or punishing is fair
game to being called reinforcement
learning ok so here I'm giving an
example it's not even human this is a
rodent who's learning a simple bandit
task the color here tells us which of
two bandits are the best at a given time
and you see that the size of the text
tells us whether the animal got a reward
or not for for this choice and you see
that the animal wants to pick green when
Green is good and orange win orange is
good etc ok so this is the kind of
reinforcement learning behavior we look
at and what's interesting here is that
if you plot the aggregated behavior so
here it's the dotted line plotting the
probability of choosing either other
bandits
this can be really captured super well
by the simple kind of algorithm we saw
before so this is where the algorithm is
coming from computer science have been
helpful in in capturing behaviors so
here we have the action value for both
of the bandits and that's capturing this
behavior really well okay so because of
that people think of them as related the
last the last third of the community is
neuroscientist and reinforcement
learning has a very specific place in in
the heart of neuroscientist because it's
been one of the success stories of
computational neuroscience in the past
20 years and that's because we
identified a region of the brain and the
region that has neurons that encode
dopamine that's happened to encode
something very very close to what we
think of as a reward prediction er is
this something you guys know or no okay
great perfect so this is what I'm
plotting here our each line is the
firing of a single neuron and the top is
aggregating this over multiple trials on
the same type and what you see here is
an animal getting a reward and you see
that those dopamine neurons increase the
spiking and so they seem to be signaling
oh something better than I was expecting
happen here after a while the animal
learns to predict this reward
so that's you can think of Pavlov's
experiment the Bell predicts the food so
that's what's yes here means and when
you get that this is where you get
dopamine signaling so that's supposed to
be our prediction er and then when you
get the reward you're expecting it and
there's no hope in signaling again and
then when the animal was expecting a
reward but did not get it that's a
there's a dip in signal so this set of
neurons seem to be encoding something
exactly what you would want for a reward
prediction er people have gone further
looked at the circuits sim who dopamine
neurons talk to and essentially what
they've learnt is that
a really well-defined circuit in the
brain that uses dopamine neurons that
have this reward prediction error to
modulate plasticity between those
neurons that encode something like a
state in those neurons back will help
you make a choice downstream that seems
to essentially be encoding this equation
with the help of used to encourage
community building and she said more
recent research in neuroscience actually
points towards this so definitely
doesn't encode re1
you can see it here right you can see
that when you get a reward here you get
a signal and you might get a reward here
you don't get a signal and that's before
before you know those those sets of
papers people full of dopamine are
encoding reward after the set of papers
they feel actually it's more reward
prediction error than reward this is a
very strongly established finding it's
always more complicated than you think
so it's it's actually not quite as
simple as a simple reward prediction er
but community building is not something
I've heard before it encourages learning
it encourages associations so it
encourages plasticity so it encourages
learning to associate something with
something else maybe that's what I don't
know no no so so people have done all
the experiments on that they've tried
the causality but there's many ways in
which you can you know for example for
Stoke mignons to fire and then you see
an effect on behavior you can people
have really intervene in all little
places of the circuit this is it's a
very strong finding it's it's more
complicated than than than than this
very simple story but I
you know if you think of your tailor
expansion that the first degree it's
right for sure after that you know it
might be a bit of but okay so we have a
circuit that's implementing this kind of
algorithm um first approximation and and
so again that's a place where people
have said well it's amazing you know you
can take an algorithm for computer
science and explain the brain and so
because of that because of this
successful link between those three
things people have tended to think of
reinforcement learning as one thing only
and even though the field has actually
known all the time that it was not right
that there's that there's that there's
lots of other things that we should
think about so for example when when
when you think of of the brain including
this algorithm you never say anywhere
well the state space or what the action
space is are over which this equation
operates okay we don't know that and
it's probable that another brain region
for example is responsible for that and
that this might have a very important
consequences for how we learn etc same
this algorithm we have here is
optimizing something fairly specific
right this expected value of the sum of
future discounted rewards but it's very
possible so that part of your behavior
is driven by other kind of cost
functions or benefit functions in which
case we would want to make good use of
all that kind of algorithms okay so
that's why I try to understand is if we
want to understand human learning or
animal learning for that matter we need
to think of those other pieces both in
the brain in computation and so what I
want to try to do today is to give you
two examples of this one is on transfer
and generalization and the other one is
on how two different systems contribute
to the behavior of learning in humans
focusing on working memory
I'm actually going to start with a
second one because I think you will be
very interested in this one especially
given what I did told me of your
previous talk and if we have time we can
talk about the other one but it's ok if
we just do a first one a second one I
guess ok so let me introduce this the
circuit we've talked about earlier that
promotes reinforcement learning system
is very well understood memory and
learning system in the brain so here you
have a brain cut like this you have the
cortex in green and then you have
elements under the cortex deeper in the
brain there are the part are crucial for
doing this reinforcement learning
computation ok so this is one one one
system one network that window works
well for doing reinforcement time
however the psychologists have known for
you know a very very long time that we
have other memory systems for example we
have episodic memory that's encoded in
this different structure the hippocampus
episodic memory people give the example
usually of it's it's the kind of memory
you use to remember where you parked
this morning you can know it very
precisely it doesn't have to interfere
with what you parked yesterday but then
when you don't need it you probably
won't remember it anymore
okay and then there's a another memory
system working memory so currently you
guys heard about this last week or two
weeks ago and working memory slightly
different it's this system where you
actively try to remember something and
you can do that for only a very little
amount of information for a very short
amount of time and it's going to be very
subject to interference okay so that's
the classic example here is the phone
number that you have to actively
remember until you use it and then it
disappears very quickly from your memory
okay so we have those three systems and
the first major question is we have
three memory systems and we only make a
single decision at a given time and so
we have to understand how they work
together
when we're learning to figure out - to
make us make choices okay so this first
system is you can think of it maybe as
the deep reinforcement learning systems
that have taken over a I RL recently
there they seem to be doing very
analogous computations long term memory
or episodic memory has also recently
made a bit of a foray into into into the
AI a reinforcement learning domain so
here I'm deciding to papers but I know
you guys also have your your own
research that includes this but I have
not seen any evidence that the AI
community is thinking much about what
working memory is contributing to learn
so I love to be contradicted by the way
they have infinite capacity they have
essentially infinite capacity right so
in that sense they're very not working
memory well in practice those are
infinite it's just a few tens of tiny
steps
right right so yeah so I thought of a
last term has this aspect of active
maintenance innocence and integration I
think there are a few crucial
differences with working memory so
working memory we think of it as being
able to maintain very precisely one
piece of information on its own or a few
pieces of information which i think is
fairly distinct in a sense of
what else teams are doing in integrating
everything in a space that we're not
completely sure exactly what information
has in the end right I think there is
something that's been demonstrated that
those teams cannot do and that is or
novel associations we maintain those for
some period of time in a flexible way
yeah they only store the types of
information that have been trained over
hundreds thousand time steps
yeah right right and also I think of
working memory as something where we can
that's an internal representation over
which we can operate so for example I
might give you a number and another
number and make you remember them and
after that ask you give me the product
of them which case you would have to
operate over them and so money play
those those representations yeah so
networks that have specific external
memory storage that they access by the
process that is mislabeled attention
yeah is that not a case of working
memory of course it doesn't it's not
intended to have yeah but it is
something that maintains yeah yeah so I
think it might be related in a sense I
think you're right the question I have
so far is for some reason we have this
limitation and it could be you know a
true limitation or it could be something
useful to to human cognition and and if
it is I haven't seen this built into any
I but but you know if you if you know
that yeah
the invention models but but also the
previous talk or working memory they all
have this feel of actually doing the
reasoning explaining away which is what
you know that puts down to like fashion
is you try to go somewhere and really
then go forward and go back it's not so
you have you have make magnets of to go
in circles like this and uh working
every favor thought we've heard from mr.
Blum was like that too that if you keep
on going back and forth and the
limitation is I guess there to promote
reasoning rather than then sort of you
know Sixth Sense kind of guessing
potentially yeah I obviously haven't
seen this talk so I can't I could really
relate that well to it but in deep RL
that is also does push on more
model-based approaches curious would you
mind getting back to this question at
the end because I feel like so relating
the work am going to the mall based mall
free framework is something that is
actually a you know a nearly 99%
confidence this question will come up is
my in my took you may feel like it's
always better explain afterwards than
before but if you want to come back to
it before that I'll be happy to yeah in
I'm lumping episodic memory and
long-term memory in one long yeah looks
I want to style two systems of cortical
memory versus so so long-term memory it
it tends to be fairly vague term right
episodic memory can be long-term and
reinforcement learning can also create
those kind of long-term associations
that can go from being subcortical to be
in cortical as as I know you know and so
and so I think of both of those as being
long-term contributing at least to the
creation of long-term memories whereas
this one is very short-term people who
study memory will divine memory into
fairly different ways though again this
isn't
oxidation not to be taken a mess face
value okay so the one I'm focusing on
right now is working memory and how it
plays a role in learning people haven't
actually looked at that too much in in
human learning
okay so I've given you know I've given
you the intuition already BAM I'm going
to make it a bit more precise so if you
remember when you were learning how to
drive you're given lots of instructions
that you if you're careful students will
try to actively keep in mind at the
beginning so for example the speed
limits remembering to signal when
turning remembering more abstract things
like the rules for how to handle a
four-way stop or a red light in the US
and also even more abstract things like
how to not kill bicyclist okay and then
and then so you'll try to actually very
actively remember this okay so you'll
keep this in your mind like okay I need
to not go faster than 25 and what at the
beginning what will environment is that
you'll forget some of those and
hopefully the worst thing that will
happen is that you'll get a ticket for
speeding or something like that okay
so that's this is illustrating two ways
in which you're learning right you're
you're actively maintaining information
and trying to apply it that's working
memory and then you're also getting
feedback when you mess up or
encouragement if you do it you're doing
well and that's reinforcement you okay
and so I think of them as as being at
two different ends of of a trade-off one
learning incremental and integrated
information in the sense of the value of
the policy that we're trying to apply
and so in that sense it's inflexible but
the positive for this is that it's a
very broad capacity and lots of things
with reinforcement learning it's robust
in the long term and it's fairly
effortless in the other direction
working memory is one-shot kind of
learning very fast it stores information
very precisely
and it's flexible we can operate over
our operations in working memory over
our information and the downside is by
its resource or capacity emitted amount
of information you can hold is limited
its is limited in time too and it's
effortful it's something that we have to
engage cognitive attention into okay so
what I wanted to do is try to develop an
experimental protocol that would help me
show that those work together during
learning and develop computational
models that will also capture this okay
so I'll explain my experimental protocol
no it's actually quite simple so if
you're a participant in this experiment
you would see an item on a computer
screen for example a pumpkin actually
it's a perfect season for us and then
you would make a choice by pressing a
key with one of one of three keys on a
keyboard and then you would get feedback
that will tell you if you pick the
correct key for this image and then you
would see another item and you would
repeat this process you would repeat it
for number of trials in the block for
example you would see the pumpkin and
the green beans 15 times each and over
time you would just be using this
feedback information here to to learn to
pick the correct action for each item
yeah there's one correct action there's
only one correct action per item a
correct action can be correct for more
than one item the feedback is
deterministic so if you have a perfect
memory you try this you try that you try
that you're done okay and then and then
you're perfect
perfect question um so in some blocks
people will see two images like this and
in other blocks they'll see three four
or five up to six images okay and that's
actually the critical manipulation
because by by having a classic
reinforcement learning experiment where
I'm giving feedback in response to
people's choices I test the
reinforcement learning part of of
learning so I see how much the the
history of feedback influences choices
but by manipulating this what I call the
set size and number of images that
people learn about I manipulate the load
on working memory and what is really
well known about working memory is that
it's called maintaining that much
information so this should affect
differently this block come back to this
book so that makes sense like to make
sure we're good here because ya know I
the the user answers each time yeah
sorry Junior yep and maybe you're gonna
tell us next what what criterion is that
user uses to choose which but what's
what are they supposed to do so at the
beginning they're going to put randomly
because they have no information yeah
exactly
yeah it's it's it's it's essentially
abandoned yeah so context jo3 armband
yes I think the instructions aren't
explicit that the feedback is truthful
deterministic that there's only one
correct action I won't change in the
block and that information about one
steamos is not informative for the other
stimuli perhaps that users should not be
equally evaluated against
yeah so that's why I do this many
different blocks that way in average you
should start at Chang's yeah let's go oh
it's going to be no no I saw of course
that the assignments are random damages
they start assuming that there is some
logic to them so humans will always
assume there's logical structure even if
they've told it there isn't yeah I tell
them I tell them that they can't infer
for example what happens often is in
wonder in the block with three images
people want to think that there's a
one-to-one mapping between images and
actions and I'll tell them that
explicitly is not the case that they
can't they can't infer the third one for
landscapes they should assume that no
because if they do start looking for
logic then that's gonna affect the whole
experiment later because they'll be
using probably different apartness than
you're talking about yeah yeah that
would correct itself from feedback but I
have you know taking lots of care to try
to minimize this kind of biases so for
example we try to make sure that the
images in the set are the same category
and have no visual structure that will
have them clump together it's it's
completely impossible to completely get
rid of this kind of you know reasoning
that's actually the second part of my
talk is people search for structures
any more questions okay so if you take
my vanilla super simple reinforcement
learning model and apply it to this task
so this one where you have reward
prediction errors that you used to
update the value of the stimulus and the
key the it's making a prediction in this
experiment that because you're learning
for one stimulus completely
independently of the other stimuli there
is not going to be any effect offset
size so if you plot if you simulate this
model on this experiment with just an
input here but they're there they're fit
to the parameter to the subjects and if
you plot here the performance of them
also probability rights choosing the
correct action as a function of so this
isn't time this is how many times you've
seen a given item okay it's making the
prediction that the set size doesn't
matter is that clear right because it's
just it's just storing the Q value for
image for the pumpkin completely
independently of the Greenies okay this
is an obvious terrible prediction when
you look at participants this is what it
looks like you post that rain change
like one third and when they have to
learn two things they're fairly close to
optimal they take three tries and then
they get richer asymptotic behavior and
then the bigger the set size the more
incremental their overall learning curve
looks like okay so this is an effect
that can't be accounted for by the
classic form of reinforcement learning
that people usually use and then you can
do all kind of tricks on this on this
reinforcement learning model so for
example you can add forgetting or you
cannot interference or you can add many
different mechanisms and try to see if
you can still force a single
reinforcement learning model to capture
the behavior and I have not been
successful so this is about the best you
can do if you just add some
getting to the Q values at each trial
you're going to get a slight effect of
site size due to the fact that when
you're learning two things you see them
every two trials in average whereas when
you're learning six things you see them
every six trials never so you have more
time to focus okay but it's clearly not
capturing the qualitative bate pattern
of behavior yeah yep yep learning
generalization between images of two
things
No No so this is the pattern you expect
with perfect memory so this is the first
time you see the pumpkin second time you
see the pumpkin third time you see the
pumpkin because you have three keys this
is the optimal pattern to have so if you
have perfect memory you'll remember I
try this I try that I try that and this
is the correct why well these are humans
so what I think this is showing is that
when we're trying to remember two things
this is still within a working memory
capacity which is able then to use it
perfectly so perfectly remember okay
this one for the pumpkin and this one
for green beans but as soon as we go a
bit beyond that it goes beyond our
working memory capacity so we don't have
that perfect yeah so the reinforcement
learning is interested because alpha is
not big enough it takes longer
absolutely yeah you could have an alpha
that's bigger and a softmax
in the stem picture that's bigger and if
you have perfect a lot well the
parameters are used here are the best
fit parameters to this behavior I don't
remember exactly
that makes sense
that's going to be very dependent on the
environment and I'm going to speak of it
about that later
but but probably not probably not
because because if it was then you would
expect that when you're within your
capacity you would be doing worse than
done when you're outside when you're
using reinforcement oh sorry this is I
see what you you're plotting this
compared to this yeah this is again fit
with parameters fit to this right and so
the again I could make this mall better
or worse you know I could put the decay
to zero and the learning rate to one and
then it would be learning perfectly for
example so there's no real point in
comparing the point of comparing those
two is to say the qualitative padding
the spray the spread the way behavior
changes with set size is much more
marked in humans than it is in the
best-fitting
reinforcement learning model that you
can have so that make sense thank you
okay so the idea here is that what I
think I'm showing is that I can't
explain the behavior of learning in this
task with a simple with only emoji of as
high as reinforcement learning I have to
account also for working memory okay so
to do that I developed a model that has
a module an expert that's reinforcement
learning the same as before and then
that also has a working memory module
that I'll talk about later and then I
assume that learning or the policy that
participants ended up taking is a
mixture of the policies of the two
experts okay so it's this idea that we
have those two learning system the
decision systems and that they are going
to
makes come together for for choice okay
so the way model the working memory
comes from what we know about working
memory outside of the domain of learning
in the domain of decision-making yeah
exactly
so it would be it's it's very very
simpler it's less this one okay some
sure is that the reinforcement the pure
reinforcement learning literature hasn't
shown any effect of of decay so I think
I think the the forgetting is a property
of working memory rather than moving
them okay so what the working memory is
doing is I'm going to assume that we
have a fixed number of items we can
maintain of in working memory so for
example three and I'm going to
parameterize that by a capacity
parameter and what this is the way I'm
going to model this is to say well three
out of out of the number of items I'm
trying to remember are going to be
stored perfectly in working memory and
your three are not going to be stopped
and I couldn't do exactly that for
technical reasons so instead what I do
is imagine that working memory has a
perfect policy one trial back but decay
over time and then that the probability
that I will be able to use this item for
my decision is going to decay with set
size when it goes below capacity okay so
it's at its at its at its maximum if the
number of items I'm trying to remember
is below capacity and then it decreases
in an inverse way
memory represents a policy and does that
mean that when we see an image there in
a rectangle on the left and one of the
three yeah choices is highlighted the
best the correct choice works the choice
of the user chose so that would be it's
the last trials information which may be
wrong well it won't be wrong because the
feedback is deterministic but it will
remember to not pick something that was
wrong it's just some information and
also I guess it's implied that it
remembers yeah so it's it's joining um
it's it's it's joining a bit all of this
actually so if I can go to a bit more
detail behind model it essentially I'm
modeling the working memory this the
same way as I do the the reinforcement
learning model with a learning rate of 1
so it has this compressed information
but it also has this decay which means
that's the policy gets worse the more
intervening trials coming and then and
then the this tells me how likely I am
to use working memory versus
reinforcement learning and it decreases
with that size and this is going to go
into the mixture wait here tell me how
likely I am to use working memory versus
no so Sarah okay so this the small has a
few free parameters that I can fit again
to participants behavior and then I have
fade those parameters I can simulate
them all again and compare to
participants and you see that
essentially we capture the behavior much
better than we did with the previous
reinforcement learning models okay so
this is just one step of showing that
this small is helpful for understanding
understanding human learning and after
many
others to validate the fact that we
really need those two modules to do to
explain human learning but I won't bore
you with the details
yeah the natural thing for me to do is
the next step would be to vary another
parameter and bury the role that
somebody gets reading successful yeah is
that but I know that in psychology
experiments aren't often rewarded
yeah have you run that experiment so
I've run a version of this experiment I
actually don't think I'll be talking
about us yeah I've run a version of this
experiment where we do manipulate the
reward we get for being correct so we
still have zero versus
deterministic information as to whether
the output is correct and then we vary
one points versus two points
probabilistically and it's a mixed
success because it's very hard to make
people actually care about reward
especially in such a long participants
here do 900 trials so any single point
they get a single trial does not have
very much influence so we end up seeing
that people are not paying that much
attention to it so I'm sure we should
probably work harder to try to
incentivize those points more if we if
we want to go there but I haven't done
perfectly and then there's a drop in
performance that's all because you can
you can actually yeah so I think my mom
for key memory so far is pretty bad
actually I think it's it's an average
moment and and it's something I'm
working on it's been very difficult to
find a better prediction of so so what's
difficult for me right now is to say I
have a capacity of 3 and I'm trying to
remember 6 things which 3 am I going to
prioritize
and there's no very good information out
there telling me how this is happening
and this is some way I can try to look
at here but it's been actually extremely
difficult to find any pattern in the way
our participants are doing that
different different ways of showing the
information and see how long it takes
them to learn because anything very
different you can see what if it's
better yeah the problem is that this is
so these are all experiments with the
thought of doing
there's many difficulties some of them
are that we assume that actually the
weight we give to working memory so I go
some of this but you see that the
maximum here is not one it's actually a
parameter to and and we actually think
that people don't have a fixed mixture
weight even for a given policy here but
over time they might say like as
reinforcement learning becomes better at
predicting you know reinforcement
learning is going to learn slower but
hours after some time is going to have
learnt well and not be sensitive to
decay which means it's going to become a
better predictor over time at which
point because we're human race effortful
we might start choosing it less even if
we can so there are very complicated
dynamics in time actually happening
there which is why it's more complicated
that it looks like to actually
understand well um what working
memorizing yeah have you looked at just
with this existing data how the
probability of being correct varies with
the amount of time since they've seen
that particular image absolutely yeah um
it's in the paper I do in this
presentation but there's a big effect of
delay that interacts both with time and
way of set size so the effect of July is
bigger in higher set sizes so there's
more forget
and it's disappears over time which i
think we think of as a marker of people
stopping using our cue memory and
starting using barrel instead so it
seems like we're assuming people are
exploiting randomly if they haven't seen
an image before yeah that's the baseline
assumption yes do we know if people are
doing or so so one alternative way that
I could see someone trying to approach a
problem like this which might make it
easier to remember what you've done in
the past would be to basically
systematically explore so rather than
actually choosing randomly you could
just say if I haven't seen it before I
get the key one I've seen it before I
hit key - I know I know after - yeah so
people definitely do that there's
actually a great paper by someone in
Germany that's actually not published
yet but on bio archive who was looking a
bit more precisely at this kind of
systematic exploration that's that's
definitely happening I'm not modeling it
here for a couple of reasons one is that
there's massive individual differences
there and so you have to end up like
saying like the quarter of my
participants do this left to right and
they were a quarter do this right -
laughs sweep and and so it probably
accounts for some of the variants but it
probably does not modify the key finding
of interest which is that working memory
um but the load effects um the longing
which is why that's something we have to
get used to when we mark Yuman learning
is that there's always going to be more
to it and your Molly's never going to be
good and so you have to focus on
specific aspects and think of a scale of
compounds and whether or not they would
influence or not you're finding and this
is the kind of thing I think which is
very interesting but we don't really
have downstream effects on the
conclusions I draw yeah so it might make
working more a bit less efficient yeah
okay so one way we can try to confirm
that this is real and related to the
brain is to to go look at neural signal
so this is me wearing an EEG cap do you
guys know about each yet oh okay great
so I can give you a two line summary eg
it's those electrodes that are on the
scalp it's completely painless perfectly
super safe it just measures electrical
activity on the scalp that is generated
by by activity inside the brain each is
great for being super precise in time so
you can resolve things at the
millisecond precision it's terrible
to know where things are happening so
you should just not conclude anything
about location in the brain based on
that but it tells us if the neural
signal is sensitive to a given signal
and one and that can be very informative
already about what computations are
happening in the brain okay it's a tiny
signal and the signal to noise ratio is
terrible which is why we need lots of
trials and you end up getting something
that looks like this
so the time zero is your event of
interest for example a presentation of a
stimulus here and then you get a
squiggly line that represents the change
in voltage as a response to the stimulus
and this is seconds so you see that
things are happening at 100 200 300
milliseconds reaction times are
somewhere around here okay when people
make they are of action so we can look
at what's happening in the decision
process before the decision okay I can
look at this so this is average over I
don't know 450 trials something like
that you can look at every single trial
um here so this is the same thing just
color-coded the voltage each line is a
trial and the x-axis this time again
okay and when you see it this way you
see that there is signal right you see
this dip here and this peak here and
that's fairly repeated and we think that
this
two important computations in the brain
okay but there's also a lot of noise
obviously okay so I can take this signal
I have this is a fairly big data this is
a single electrode here I have this four
sixty four different electrodes over the
brain and I can try to say well when I
look at the signal is there anywhere in
the signal that is related to my two
expert my reinforcement learning experts
in my working memory expert okay so to
do that I can extract from the model
components that relates to computations
so for example the Q values are the
reward prediction errors of the
reinforcement learning signal and for
working memory I can just look at the
set size for example because that's
something that should matter for working
memory okay so I can I can take those
variables for each trial and I can just
try to kind of do multiple regressions
in sheet so try to explain the voltage
across all trials for a given time point
and electrode as a function of those
predictors that I know matter that make
sense okay and so when I do that I end
up with a regression wait that tells me
how well different given regressor
explains the signal at a time and a
point of interest and then try to see
how consistent this is across
participants across time and electrodes
okay so that's the method and so I'm
going to plot here is the results so
from the time with the most to the time
of the choice here and focusing it on
the reinforcement learning process of
the working memory process so when I'm
do that around 300 milliseconds I find a
number of electrodes here that are
sensitive to a reinforcement learning
process specifically here the Q value
predicted by the reinforcement learning
process and know know where in the brain
sensitive to to working memory process
okay if I look a bit later on I'm at 500
milliseconds I find the reverse I find
lots of electrodes
sensitive to that size
creatively the working memory process
and numb to the reinforcements yes so
that's a way of showing that I've kind
of isolated those two processes it
matches what we know about the brain
that reinforcement learning kind of
decisions are easy and fast very very
very automated in the sense where this
is more effortful it takes more time for
the brain to do the computation and
actually apply it okay so it kind of
validates in a way and what I've
extracted from the behavior of real malo
relates to the brain do that make sense
okay so it shows that we can retrieve
those two processes and that distinct
but then I can write so then I can make
use of this to try to understand a bit
better what computations are happening
on the road so that would be yeah so I'm
going to show you how we do that so
before that I I like to remind you that
I think we've seen two processes here
that are really at different ends of of
a trade-off working memory is optimized
for storing information very precisely
very quickly but not in the long term or
as RL is optimized for storing lots of
things in the long run but that takes
more time for it to get there okay and
so the next question I had in this line
of research was to ask what what the
interaction might be so first how they
would decide you know how they would
compete for for choice in a sense but
even more importantly how independent
those two processes are and usually when
we think of having two processes that
are experts at different ends of a
trade-off you want them to be as
independent as possible so that they can
do their own job well and then be used
whenever it's more useful for them to be
used so I tried to see if that was the
case or if there was an interaction
between them and to do that I'm going to
focus again on those signals so here
this is an average signal this is just
saying that
the the signal in the brain is
correlated where the activity of the
predicted by the reinforcement learning
model in this task and I can do the same
thing when the participants get feedback
and I find an area of the brain I
shouldn't say that I find some signals
in the brain that are related to the
reward prediction error at feedback okay
so I'm going to take those signals and
I'm going to look at them a bit more
carefully and see how they evolve as a
function of off learning and again if
reinforcement learning and working
memory are independent then those
signals that I think relate to
reinforcement learning should also be
independent of working memory processes
and in particular they should be
independent of that size okay so if this
is really representing the reinforcement
learning systems q-value then it should
look something like this right it should
look like something that goes up with
with past reward and independently of
that size and for our prediction error
it should be robust go down with past
rewards and then and then and be
dependent of setsize do that make sense
the premise here okay so I can look at
that I can just extract the signal at
each trial and then we plot it
differently so why I'm plotting here is
it's a neural learning curve in the
sense so it's the signal that is related
that that is in this region that's
sensitive to reinforcement learning
processes and plotting it as a function
of how many previous rewards the
participant has experienced for the
current image so far and what you see is
that this goes up that's what you expect
of a Q value so that's the way I
selected this signal so that's normal
but we see this but what you see is that
it goes up more slowly for the lower set
sizes or the easiest learning problem
then for the harder one okay so that
could be full of as a bit weird
uhm don't see what this is showing is
that sorry it's not drops is increases
sorry
wrong so the egq value signal increases
slower for low set sizes than for high
societies so the way we could interpret
this is that somehow in low set sizes
we're using working memory for learning
we can because it's within capacity and
maybe somehow this is blocking the
reinforcement learning um okay this is
what will happen if you had to lower
learning rate or something like that
okay but then I looked at the same thing
at a time of feedback the reward
prediction error and if we're imagining
that we're blocking the reinforcement
learning signal then the reward
prediction errors should remain high
right because you're not learning
instead what we're saying is that the
reward prediction errors do drop the the
signals in the brain that code
prediction errors do drop with
experience of reward but they drop
faster for for those sizes than for
hiset size okay so it can't be that
working memory is blocking around
otherwise we would expect the opposite
we would expect those purple line here
to be over the orange line instead what
it looks like here is that this is
dropping faster for the things that are
being learned faster okay so it looks
like actually working memory knows what
the outcome should be and seems to be
contributing to the computation of this
reward prediction error saying like I
pick this action for the pumpkin I know
I'm going to get rewarded yeah yeah
faster it's the four five and six images
all this everywhere higher - right it's
not just it's not that everything is the
same mean at time at the first
observation oh this is actually not
different okay yes okay and we can we
actually have a much more precise
statistical evidence for this but I
haven't shown here but yeah okay so so
instead of thinking of reinforcement
learning as this closed loop
system that does its own reward
prediction error this makes a thing of
working memory as contributing to this
reward prediction error but it's funny
right because because working memory is
learning faster it's actually going to
mess up with the reward prediction error
and make our land slower yeah no we
would expect the same here because here
yeah because rewarding history is
equated so if reinforcement learning did
not care about that side we should
expect no interaction of that size with
reward history so that you might have
expected if with various more cognitive
accounts like all people are paying more
attention or it's easier or it's
something like that yeah right
so which is why we want to see if this
which is why we wanted to see this was
actually related to behavior so this
makes a very clear prediction which is
that if the reinforcement learning
signal is being blunted when working
memory is being used essentially it
means that the Q values you're learning
are going to be weaker than they would
be otherwise and the way we can test
that is to do the same experiment as
before so this is relating showing the
same experiment as before where we
expect better performance for little
than hiset size but then we can after
that at the end of the experiments give
a surprise test face or tell people oh
now you're going to go back through
every image you've seen every or 80 MHz
to sin and you're going to have to pick
the correct choice and I'm not going to
give you any feedback okay and that's a
way to see what is
remaining of their policy that they've
learned previously and it can't be
working memory anymore because it's way
beyond capacity in time range of working
memory and so in a way that way we can
probe what's remaining in the
reinforcement learning system the policy
and what this predicts is that you
should have the reinforcement learning
system we'll have lunch worse in no set
size and so that we will actually
remember less well what we've performed
on better before than vice versa which
is not at all prediction that people
would normally make okay so when I did
this experiment I got what I was
expecting in in learning so this is
proportion of car trials for society or
size six at the end of learning and here
I'm plotting the difference between six
five three and six so this is positive
it's just the same as before and then
when you do a testing you get this
reversal this nice interaction where
said sy6 performance is actually better
than sit sighs okay so it completely
flips okay so somehow working memory has
had this influence why it's made you
it's easier for you to learn a few
things at the beginning but it's made
you learn it last well in the long term
okay so this seems this and various
other aspects of the neural computation
that I haven't shown you makes a thing
that this is what's happening instead of
our computations happening in closed
loop the word humor system is
contributing this expectation to the
reward prediction error and in that
sense messing up where the computations
of value are happening in the
reinforcement learning that makes us
okay so this is why I'm at now and the
experiment I'm running now in my lab are
trying to understand why we would do it
why this would be happening it's a bit
confusing when you think about it
because the goal of the reinforcement
learning system is to encode something
strongly in the long term okay and so
and it's thought of being effortless and
happening in the background and by by
having this this interference here
you're essentially preventing
reinforcement learning of being able to
do its job right after being able to do
its job of letting you remember well
later yeah
so I actually I'm not sure that it says
exactly that I would think that in this
particular example that's what it
provides evidence of but it's unclear
that you know where the subjects told it
look you're going to be tested on this
next post and you will be giving no
feedback and there's some you know goal
of you memorizing that and so I'm just
optimizing for a system in the short run
we've seen that it's actually optimal
potentially to be using my my working
memory yeah there aren't optimize this
task yep
and so to have us and so subsequently
then have a different task yeah it seems
like you're moving the goalposts a
little bit I am yeah
but the question is if I'm going to
bother running around the background why
should I run it in a way that's about
tempo if I'm going to be but because it
in the short run it would be better to
have error running the normal way
because it would make you a loan faster
wherever your working memory fails and
in long term you would be in most
experimenting will be better to also
have let's around learn its own way
because then you would be able to
remember better so within this
experiment even if I told participants
it would in any case be better to not
have working memory interfere with it
because if you're assuming that you can
use working memory without without
creating Bissinger friends
I mean so you just tried the
reinforcement learning it's costless but
just cuz it's not it's not thinking like
conscious thought but I think these are
any like brain functioning areas it's
gonna cost it yeah yeah it's a great
question I I don't have positive
evidence for that there's this there's a
number of evidence there's a number of
you know indices that make us think that
that's the case one of them is that this
is the system that's shared across
across lots of lots of species it's very
old and because of that we think rights
it's a system that running in the
background that you can't just easily
shut off essentially and and that's
that's Linnaeus to one of our hypotheses
actually that this might be a way to
actually shut off the system in a way in
a roundabout way right like you're
saying isn't she I've predicted this
don't bother learning it but it's still
learning right it's just learning with a
prediction error of zero essentially and
and and and then the question is well
why in which environment can I imagine
this being useful to turn off
reinforcement learning okay so the the
questions we are we can ask ourselves is
what is the potential benefit of turning
off working memory this way in this
specific way that we've found well why
is that maybe watching my radars and
just contribute to this reward
prediction Herber actually contributes
to the expectation of value that the
Aral system has and that maybe this has
beneficial even prior to the learning
step that might lead to better
performance now i we've already talked
about those costs so then the question
is whether reinforcement learning is job
since it's its job it's the function is
optimizing is to help in the long run
rather than in the tauren is why we
would be interfering here
okay so it could totally be you know
suboptimal by product of evolution we
tend to assume that's probably not the
case just because evolution because we
tend to be proven false when we think
that in psychology so what we're
thinking that there might be
environments are more realistic in which
this is actually helpful is that working
memory is we used to perform computation
or multiple time steps so in between
seeing images users can be thinking and
so that depends what they think about
can also be used by the RL yeah so
you're thinking of so we don't have very
strong evidence that yeah that's a great
great idea so the idea is that there
could be offline around happening in
between trials right we actually don't
have great evidence now that's happening
in humans or even in in in animals but
that's something people think about a
lot us as something potentially
happening in and then you would be right
that that would be it was of the order
of the second so it was a fairly fast
yeah I was a fairly fast-paced
experiment the participants actually
perform better if we leave them more
time so we do think something like that
is probably happening but yeah that's a
good idea
another an idea that we think might be
happening is that working memory is
optimized for learning fast and being
flexible and so potentially the times
where your best are choosing working
memory are in environments that change a
lot in which case actually having
reinforcement learning that's in
flexible learn might actually hurt you
because you might be using this and in
having her
I'm unlearning when the environment
changes so that that might be a way to
adapt better so we're trying to test
this now okay
so we're definitely not going to have
time for the second part so I'm just
going to to jump to my conclusion yeah
no problem
okay so I'm just going to jump to my
conclusion I think so
after need one example of the research
now I'm where I'm trying to understand
what the computations and one of the
brain systems are that contribute to
reinforcement learning in humans and
really the key point of it is that that
it's very important to think of it as
multiple systems rather than a simple
single system and that multiple systems
in interaction that that might provide
very interesting dynamics in different
environments and I've benefited a lot
from the research right you guys do you
know like cognition and neuroscience
have taken lots of inspiration from from
AI research over time like we've been
introducing model-based reinforcement
learning and options hierarchical
reinforcement learning framework and
bashed up so bomarc of the same
processes and many other things come
directly from you know nips and stuff
like that but I do think there's also a
potential for reverse benefits we're
thinking of of the the cognition the
behavior might inform potentially better
AI so for example working memory the
other example I didn't talk about was
generalization attention planning
exploration
it's a try the way humans do that might
inform better algorithms and also
looking at the brain and saying how the
brain is implementing those systems
might also tell us something so again I
haven't talked to you about that part of
my research
oh but for example we have this
dopaminergic system that we know is
implementing something like a reward
prediction error that helps us learn
those values so if we learn more about
dopamine and learn of things it is
sensitive to that we wouldn't expect a
prayer that could be a window into
knowing what counts as a reward where is
the reward function that matters for
learning in humans so and people have
been doing that they've seen like for
example that sub-goals have effects on
dopamine or that we treat gains and
losses differently
well that uncertainty has some effects
on on dopamine or novelty etc and so
that could that are the species of
informations also thing that could
potentially feed back into into ok is in
my lab thank you very much we don't have
correspondence yes I mean I I can't
think of it more in the behavior than in
the and the brain side of my work but
that that will have been my second part
of my talk is it so the other half of my
research is focused on trying to
understand how we how humans learn more
interesting behavior hierarchical
behavior and how we and how this allows
us to generalize so an example I like to
give is you know I've never been in this
room before and despite that I know
perfectly well how to behave in this
room right it's a conference room I have
a whole set of behaviors that's
associated with that I can reload
immediately and make make users and even
if it looked very different from any
conference room I had sinned before I
would know how to do that so there's
something very very high-level about
this this inference and so part of my
work has been to try to understand how
we create this structure for learning
and something very interesting that I've
been able to show there is that it's
really a creation process rather than a
discovery process that's participants we
were talking about a little bit earlier
but that participants search for
structure and often find more structure
than there is for real and create this
structure and this is a very costly
process and behavior actually that's
something else actually I've shown that
that it's has a cost in how fast we
learn how efficiently we make decisions
etc but it comes out of a very great
benefit down the line of being able of
having created representations are
flexible enough that we can generalize
them and transfer them and everything
I've seen off generalization and
transfer in AI has been discovery rather
than creation so I haven't seen again I
might be completely wrong and I'd love
to be proven wrong actually but but I
haven't seen really any ice you know
doing more work for themselves and they
issued like creating more complex
representation than they should in a way
as a way to to to learn better later and
that's something that I've seen not just
in in adults but I've seen 18 8 month
old infants and other people have seen
it in rodents so it seems like a fairly
core important aspect of learning
optimization and you can think of it
also as exploration because once you
have those high-level kind of strategies
instead of exploring at a low level you
can explore at a more strategic level
and and in I don't know yeah it's I
don't know it's I've tried to think
about it and it feels like it would be
really hard yeah but it seems like a
really important aspect though that's
just curious did you do any experiments
regarding secretion easier making tests
rather than context job any task or if
not you got any insights on like how to
do this
yeah so that's kind of going back to the
mall based are you thinking about mall
based reinforcement learning yeah I
haven't done much um on sequential
decision making tasks I'm actually doing
one right now that's trying to test the
options hierarchical enforcement
learning framework and how how humans
build options and it's very promising
but that's the only sequential learning
task I've done the the reason I've done
that is that everybody knows about my
base frame right yeah so it's actually
taking the computational cognitive
neuroscience community by you know as a
tsunami like in the last few years and
and people have started viewing learning
as the thing that has to be either about
three or more base reinforcement
learning directly imported from you know
something about doors like like that and
what I've been trying to show is that
it's really much too crude of
Junction will you seen this kind of
tasks
there's no sequential running right
which is their convey any planning for
our planning right so which means that
mo Basin vol 3 would be doing exactly
the same thing in this task and despite
that we still find those really
important associations right and people
studying more based reinforcement
learning and humans have said well it is
dependent on working and it is true it
is but what what this shows I think is
that my basement floor planning is a
very big thing that has many cognitive
little pieces in it and it's not this
current Association that phil has been
trying to pretend it is and so I'm
trying to step back and be a bit a bit
cleaner even yeah it's right answer your
question Jeff yeah it sounded like what
you were saying about humans looking for
structure is basically saying that we
also over fit when we're trying to learn
it's really it's a bit more than that
yeah it's a bit more than that so
there's definitely some of that so
that's this really cool experiment
that's it's a super simple experiment
where people just see a stream of ones
and zeros oh I think it's the black and
white dots or something like that but
see for all intents and purposes it's a
stream of binary variable randomly
picked with probably 2.5 and if you just
look at their reaction times you see
that if you have one zero one zero but
will be much so what people have to say
is press write for one and zero for four
for life so it's no learning no decision
rang I just press as fast as possible
and pouring what you see on the screen
well you see if is is that a various
local structure in the sequence even
though it's random first of all one zero
and zero four will be much faster and
string one then they will be a ten
strings year after that or there's one
point one day people trusted and string
one
so in essence that's exactly overfitting
saying
this local structure it's more regular
than we think it is and we're predicting
the next one based on this very local
structure that's that's our thing I
would interpret it this way to be the
type of thing I do goes with beyond that
because we're we're essentially creating
variables that don't exist and that they
are not needed if it's a bit hard to
explain without having having introduced
the question but it's it's more than
overfitting it's it's creating more
structure than there is out there yeah
yeah so in the case where where they
were pretty die faster what makes you
want zero one zero and things like that
was there any cost son other words were
they slower it goes one zero one zero
zero
yes yes yeah it goes in both directions
and that's a fairly standard training is
that is that anywhere you have transfer
you'll have both positive and they get
to transfer like you'll benefit if if
you're into situation where you can
apply in your hybrid costs there's real
costs it's a it's a really important
aspect of it that's your costs both
immediately and I was just thinking to
get more on the more of your thoughts on
discovery versus creative yeah a lot of
the work that I've seen in the yes I
don't think cities we focus on sample
complexity and like why building these
options or these things put lower sample
common distribution of that yeah I'm
curious about your hypothesis for what
the actual cost function might be that
you're trying to go after so yeah
there's a at least three different
hypotheses there that I haven't much to
go back yet future work one is
so so one can be friendly in one of two
ways one is that we just have a prior
for babbling structure and because we
have that tire until the program wrong
we'll just end up in that structure and
that could reflect just the statistics
or an environment where we expect it to
be beneficial in the long run which case
you could frame this as a as a cost
function that's will be ability - I
guess being directed to analyze later
another one is some kind of divide and
conquer process where when you build
structure often it allows you to make
multiple simpler choices rather than one
more complex choice and so that might be
a way to you have to do - to cut the
trowel in a way that's more tractable
another is interference lowering
adjustments is that if you create new
representations for claims they are
similar you might be able to call those
representations apart a bit more in such
a way that will make it harder for them
to interfere when you're learning it
slightly different but in slightly
similar but context but with that
require fairly kind of similar I think
of this a lot because this is a laptop
with a French keyboard and I have a
laptop that looks nearly the same and
has an English keyboard in the
interference between them it's horrible
and so and I think that's because I
don't use them equally but if I did I
would probably be able to very quickly
switch from one to the other
yeah so one specific question about this
additional structure thing because I
think it's just super fascinating by the
way your whole talk and research engine
I think in thanks for
but it strikes me based upon the
explanation that you just gave the
additional structure is a more
complicated representation of the state
space yeah in a reinforcement learning
problem state in actions may say so the
actions state the action space as well
so could you need a specific example
about how the human actor might have a
more complicated representation of the
action space would it be like a
conditional action space though 22:2
actions in a row as opposed to each
action being unique yeah um this is not
the best slide for that but I'm going to
try to do that so sorry what's with this
this
yeah that's one
okay I always have super simplified who
problems and and and and I had a great
example with computers and different
operating systems before a night and
then I came here and realized there was
Linux and and I cannot windows in my
presentation so so if you're learning
this if you're if you're learning this
your state space could be those six
images and here we have four actions and
you could just run those six
associations what I've been working on
showing instead is that what people are
more likely to do so you might recognize
here that actually the red and gray
shapes have the same correct action is
that people will learn for example here
in this case to select rule TSU is short
for task set - that means role
essentially
I'll probably see if you want so that
people will learn to select a rope in
response to the color and then when they
have selected the Rope they'll use it to
decide that policy other shapes which is
this shape and action thing and so in
and so the way you can think of this is
that essentially what I've shown is by
essentially you can explain this as
people doing RL over to state and action
spaces in power so you'll have one loop
here that's learning the value of an
action in response on policy force
acting in action or supposed to a shape
and and I'm framing this in in terms of
network in the brain here but it doesn't
matter in another that's operating in a
more abstract state in action space
that's this context ro state in action
space and then you of course have to
create a dependency between them
but but yes so that's that's essentially
the same
Erol computation cannot happen over
those two stadium action spaces in Paulo
and that will explain a whole bunch of
behavior in terms of how people and so
it seems to me like the right
experimental variation this world would
be how this human decision makers
operate in dynamic systems that are
rapidly changing versus those that
aren't now because basically these sort
of rules become more costly in those
situations yeah yeah absolutely
so that's going to to hit against the so
when you do that you have to have a way
to identify whether people are some of
those assets or those rules to convince
yourself that they are doing that and
that's going to be even harder it's
already very hard in non-moving
environments it's going to be even
harder
removing environment so that's the
primal studying complex human learning
is that choice here this trade-off where
you lead more complex experiments to
review to see more interesting behavior
but that that comes from the drawback
off of things very hard to infer what
participants are are doing so but yeah
you're like